this is arcade mania tell my wife I'm
sorry oh my god that fee
I think the first see we'd be round in a
Stephen uterus cuz it was so funny yeah
we I was that was amazing it is very
rare I rewind something because it's so
funny and I just want to see it again in
fact that really killed me oh this is an
episode we are horrible this is just I
love it a game that talks back to here
and it's like you see like in your or
what crazy taxi cab does that do it's
just like you know you're douche bag
okay that's that but oh you know I love
crazy taxi as a game I hate the voices
when you have to crazy
um yes that would you look so they stop
this monster and these little spikes
drill into the ground all those things
are very creative the stars that turn to
have rails and chase after the little
ones I'm like oh my god
King daisies oh it's so it's so cruel so
Stephen decides they deserve a reward so
he takes them introduces them to an
arcade Oh which I was gonna say are they
even are they even still around outside
of like a Chucky Cheese or I can chant a
castle or something you thought okay
listen yeah I okayed still around I
always hear they're like dying out like
unless it's like like I said apart
they're just like it they're just
different now it used to be about being
a lazy ass pushing buttons now the only
way to ex or something
we're gonna make you dance fuck that
noise I paid that the fight that I hate
the best you all what I do like anyone
we get to punch something I really like
those ah yeah I do really like the ones
like what she destroyed um but so he
introduces them and they are all online
but then they're all terrible except for
garnets yeah and she gets addicted so
you should poster crashing the things
what I he show everybody charge flows
it's just like you know your
I had a Bob's Burgers moment where I'm
like well wait a second like you should
really put pearl on the skeeball cuz she
would get that and you should put
amethyst on the road rage one because
she would understand how to crash things
I was like oh my god why am i analyzing
this um but I got a garnet right a
little too right because she gets too
addicted to the game uh they even take
off the glasses and fine she has a third
eye that I guess she keeps closed
oh and only the third I was addicted to
the game which I thought was interesting
I don't know what that means
um but I don't have this theory that
when you play video games you engage
some other part cuz like you always kind
of zone out yeah so I kind of like my
driving or something I think it's a
metaphor for that like your third eye is
playing like you're just like a zombie
like something else kicks in something
subconscious yeah but the spikes come
back and he has to break her away from
the game and eventually he finally does
that and they go save the day while
Steve has to clean up hit the arcade by
the guy who was also the wrestling
that's irking at least now we know what
he does during the day oh I like that
cat I was much of that guy as possible.i
because it Hill the little ones they've
come back Mike yeah cuz you killed it
y'all it is um but uh I'm sorry I just
lost it there it's like chase after the
little ones I'm like holy shit
pretty violent um thank God no it's
assistant let them game and then like
that that wasn't the smart move either
but uh I I mean I guess they were right
just kill kill the ball so uh yeah I
guess I guess I do like that the show
doesn't shy away from violence so I
didn't just ya know I noticed a lot of
shows that kind of Barbra it's weird
because we're in a strange time where
every
less violence in kitchens with violence
in kid shows which I'm not totally sad
just adorable adorable violence
assistant if I buy these interesting
ways around it that in many respects
make it even more violent um but kinda
evens like Ninja Turtles and stuff like
that will make a robots that way they
can do whatever they want to open stuff
but here it's like there will have them
just disappear yeah but there's still
like these living things they're still
like you know they have insides and
organs and stuff like that so but I
don't know I don't care I am the shadows
the Sun does not come up without the
other uh but yeah I don't think kids
think that much about it anyway um
although I do kind of remember lots of
kids saying like you know to post or
Pacific families Duke I read no they're
all clones right or whatever the fuck
you call the clones all of show me don't
count I guess it's like they're still
alive but uh but the same time I also do
like and just I get it just different
mindset you know um but uh yeah I guess
this is about game addiction um see I
mean it's a game she's addicted to but
player to your barbecue but yeah I mean
I don't know I didn't feel like they
dive too much into it cuz you know
they're you get addicted to anything and
there are people are really addicted to
games um but I guess just on very basic
kid level is just good to show like not
to get too addicted oh because you may
need to fight the offspring of some
parent monster you killed yes although I
don't know if it's names old blood
especially nowadays I don't know if it's
like arcade games that people are
addicted to anymore it's much more of a
home stuff because you can go online and
there's so many worlds and stuff like
that whatever we're two old dudes
talking as if we have a fucking clue
crying hey you play Skyrim
what are you Millennials play nowadays
this is Stella's geezers you still play
in the Donkey Kong's um Pacman's in your
combat your Atari 2600 and um oh yeah I
mean it was fine super me
arrey over others the one thing
artistically like I said it was just a
little thing they did need to add but I
thought was kind of nice as when they go
into the arcade the Sun is coming up and
you see sort of like the Sun slowly hit
the man it's like there's really no
reason for that you could have cut it
but you know I am into it oh but there's
just a nice little thing and I love
little additions like that and yeah I
mean I mean my favorite times of the day
it's actually the sunrise and sunset I
mean I love any show they can represent
that very well and I thought just
showing the sunset come over was it I
guess a it not me a bunch of nice little
touch um and uh yeah sure I think what
else um it she has a third I know you
know that was a discovery I'm sure
that'll come in handy later and above
all a B we see her without the shades as
well um and that was a big reveal
sure so what it is wit in this kind of
weird seeing her without the shades cuz
I me especially see her eyes are just
like so big and so open it's like it was
like she was naked sister said that's it
that's not how I expected her eyes to
look at me it just kind of like no see
his eyes mr. Corelli kept open like yeah
here's the thing see that was a that was
that was a giveaway I knew was coming
because the first episode of Steven
universe I saw she had to take the
glasses off there was something had
something to do with knowing the future
and and she took it off um so but I I
don't know what episode that is when we
encounter and I'll say this is the
episode I saw but it definitely was
after this one cuz it wasn't this
episode yeah I knew when when the
glasses came off in three eyes it wasn't
a shock to me that was one thing I knew
was coming and I think I saw an episode
where I saw she had three eyes - um I'm
not blue fiends oh no no I I think I saw
but it was still just good
of it well no it's interesting that the
reveal is like not only does she had
three eyes but only that one is shiny
being colored and see like the only that
one was really watching it too so it
gives serve an intrigue of like what
what is that third eye what why was only
that one colored and not the other two
and why is it blind yeah what food I
belong look I know cuz she does actually
close it you know when it's done so it
is interesting um but it is just when
you finally see her eyes and like I said
it's not like a big moment where it's
like you know she's it's not like blues
bars where she shows his like they're
beautiful looking eyes or it's like you
have the cool hip open eyes a bit like
oh that's like these big wide eyes kind
of interesting reveal but what is clear
eyes your eyes is awesome ah so you were
so uh yeah good good episode um are
there are kids around that out I leave
them the comments I'm curious I'd of
like a Chucky Cheese arcade right is
golf Mill's out in a miles Heiser yeah
okay and the only place I ever seen more
cons um like it that is what it takes
account look forward to because they
have like the old consoles and stuff
like that or reveal old like machines I
mean of the two malls next to us there
aren't any arcades but that doesn't mean
they don't exist
on I mean I'm sure there's like one or
two but are they still like I mean is I
never know wanna close there's like
galloping ghosts there's old 80s like
yeah that's like that's where we don't
go eighties 90s like classic games
um but yeah they're not as big as they
used to be no I mean why even if
everything's just that home now anyway
would you
well contract I mean cadets the thing
come between personal computers and
consoles everything caught up yeah like
so the old as well so the idea that
you're going to pump a bunch of quarters
into a machine to give you something
that you could do at home yeah I pay one
point out become whatever you want it
but now that there's still around I see
them not as prevalent as I mean used to
be I swear to God every single mall had
one sometimes with some walls here too
there was and now I feel like it's every
three malls I see has one somewhere like
there actually was I had service similar
experience when like Mike my wife sister
was coming into town for whatever reason
she loves to go to a giant castle which
is kinda like a Chuckie Cheese place and
I don't know why she just loves going
there playing the games and like our
teacher she's a crank Oh cuz they had a
giant RK then like yeah it's a quite
evil pretty calm but but yeah for
whatever reason I was like I had a few
what I'm talking with cuz that's how I
get you uh and there was like a Pink
Panther game like whatever just try it
just one face I mean like dude oh yeah
dude oh dude yeah right if there's a big
pants again all you do you just go down
this like you just got a few levels he
just goes through these little pits and
those lasers coming down you just have
to get through the pits before the laser
comes down and it was insanely fucking
hard and this is like for little kids
just what I'm just playing this I lost
the first of all can just be a little
training I try it again as well those
were like every quarter is a turn I need
a total idiot like we just suck at
idiots and I was the idiot cuz I just
kept putting in these tokens I'm just
like god dammit I will beat this fucking
guy Oh at least beat this first level
maybe this one level I don't know but I
will fucking get far and the more like
whatever points or jewels you got the
more tickets you got you know will get
me back home but I I was just like shit
humming oh I didn't have a cost like 400
you're lucky you would get a used candy
wrapper for us but like I kept pumping
the tokens and do this out like holy
shit this is what a shocking event was
once a Werther's original I just can't
wait it's like of all the stupid dumbass
games again addicted to like I just
could not believe cuz it was just always
over so fast he just so we think all
right the next one I could get this is
so stupid I had to be able to beat this
goddamn game it's so simple and it was
just like now he don't be talking about
so yeah that was uh why didn't you just
go to last skee-ball in the row and just
keep pumping him in the 15 no I wasn't
doing for that it wasn't like a big
kitty bang hole no it wasn't for the
tickets it was for the honor of beating
this game I didn't even know existed in
no
would care if I won except me so I
believe that Pink Panther game and I did
not find a way baby I think I got worse
and workers more inflated sad display
it's a hard thing to confess but you
know what this episode convinced me that
it's good to get it out there and not be
ashamed so I I think you should be
ashamed I am ashamed I'm very ashamed
good good
don't play Pink Panther you'll uh you'll
never come calling stop the flashbacks